the City of Seattle made history on
Monday when it raised the minimum wage
the highest in the nation by far five
years ago Seattle became the first city
to pass a $15 minimum wage I think it's
pretty awesome since I benefit from it
but a rising tide raises all boats 15 in
Seattle is just a beginning
we have an entire woe to win sorry dad
when the law passed we went to Seattle
to interview people about it it's it's a
good thing that we're leading the way
for the rest of the country I wish that
it was all over the place not just
Seattle increasingly it is New York
State taking steps towards a $15 an hour
minimum wage other states and lots of
cities of copied Seattle California
Governor Jerry Brown signed a $15
minimum wage bill but now the results
from Seattle are in some people are
being paid more they're the winners but
for many people who wanted jobs the
increase the minimum wage is having an
opposite effect costing thousands of
jobs and naturally hurting low-income
workers you see it on this graph the
Green Line tracks the number of new jobs
created in Washington State the red line
is new jobs in Seattle
once Seattle raised its minimum to $15
entry-level job growth stalled it's
really presented by minimum-wage
advocates as a win-win it's a win-win
for employers it's a win-win for workers
and you know there are no negatives but
there are negatives as Erin Shannon of
the Washington Policy Center she points
to stories like this one where the owner
used to hire kids and train them but
once the adil raised the minimum
she stopped hiring beginners politicians
in Seattle especially have no sense
whatsoever about what it means to small
businesses like us
most people we interviewed said the
politicians are right yes some people go
out of business
others will take their place it's
something we need to do it's as if
they've never learned about supply and
demand minimum wage actually hurts my
chances of getting employed this 20 year
old understands the effect better than
Seattle's politicians did raising the
minimum
which causes increased unemployment
rigel Nova cosa is one of the $1500
winners of a video contest done by my
classroom charity my name is Dylan Hodes
and this is my weed reach Dylan Hodes
won the high school video contest he
mentioned a friend who worked at Kroger
until her store raised its minimum to
twelve dollars she was getting paid $12
an hour
um but slowly but surely they started
cutting her days her hours she was
regulated to only working on Sundays and
that's because she was young and
inexperienced I feel the bigger wasn't
worth 12 she wasn't worth 12 bucks to
Kroger she's worth the world to me but
she wasn't worth about bucks to Kroger I
learned things from their videos like
how many wealthy countries have no
minimum wage countries such as Iceland
Norway Sweden and Switzerland nobody
knows that no no and especially with
Switzerland which has much lower
unemployment than America partly because
Switzerland has no minimum it stops us
from actually getting a job Esther
Rhoades won the high school essay
contest her essay pointed out that
America's first minimum wage laws were
racist at the time blacks were often
paid less but they were more likely to
be employed than whites the whites were
like hey they're getting all the jobs
this isn't fair congressman Allgood said
he hoped the minimum wage would stop
cheap colored labor in competition with
white labor so although Americans think
the minimum was invented to help needy
people it was meant for the opposite to
keep the poor and the minorities from
getting jobs and today it still keeps
entry-level workers from finding work
but the politicians don't understand the
downside lift up the minimum wage to at
least $15 now raising the minimum wage
to 15 bucks an hour it's easy to see why
a higher minimum wage is so popular on
the surface you think oh this is a great
idea because it raises some people's
wages everybody deserves a living wage
but while it helps some it harms many
others especially young people who may
now not be offered their first job I'm
14 and be very difficult for me to find
a job my labor wouldn't be worth
fifteen dollars an hour if only
politicians were as smart as those kids